[Música]
día de reuniones diplomáticas para
intentar frenar la crisis entre rusia y
occidente por el despliegue de tropas
rusas en la frontera con ucrania
el presidente francés emmanuel majón se
reunió con su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin en moscú mientras alemania y eeuu
muestran su alianza con un encuentro en
washington
se solucionó la crisis política en el
congreso de honduras los diputados
disidentes que habían elegido a otro
presidente del legislativo respaldaron
la junta directiva de la mandataria
xiomara castró los detalles desde
tegucigalpa
y chile comenzó a aplicar la cuarta
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19 en
los mayores de 55 años es el primer país
de américa latina en administrar la
tendremos reporte desde santiago
buenas noches y bienvenidos de nuevo a
las noticias de france 24 los acompaña
mar y aclara calle y hoy fue un día de
encuentros diplomáticos con miras a
disminuir las tensiones entre rusia y
occidente
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
recibió a su homólogo francés emmanuel
bajo en moscú y los dos mandatarios
reiteraron la importancia de mantener
las conversaciones mientras que el
presidente de eeuu joe biden se reunió
con el canciller alemán olaf scholz para
evaluar respuestas conjuntas ante una
eventual invasión rusa a ucrania sin
lograrlo debido a los desencuentros por
el oleoducto ruso que surtirá a alemania
llamado nor swing 2 manuel acá no tiene
los detalles
frenéticos encuentros diplomáticos para
desescalar la crisis entre rusia y
occidente en moscú el presidente
vladimir putin recibió a su homólogo
francés emmanuel marco durante más de
cinco horas sin resultados concretos
pero con la intención de seguir
dialogando y
construir juntos respetando nuestros
fundamentos garantías concretas de
seguridad para los estados miembros de
la unión europea para los estados de la
región
ucrania georgia belarús y para rusia es
exactamente la ambición que debemos
perseguir la ambición de un poco estamos
en contra de la ampliación de la otan
con los dos miembros hacia el este
primero porque esto nos plantea la
amenaza de la ampliación continua de lo
de la otan hacia nuestras fronteras
son los estados de la otan los que se
están acercando a rusia no somos
nosotros los que estamos yendo hacia la
frontera en washington el presidente
estadounidense joe biden recibió al
canciller alemán olaf scholz los
mandatarios pusieron sobre la mesa las
posibles sanciones a rusia de invadir
ucrania y la casa blanca endureció el
tono sobre las consecuencias sin contar
con el visto bueno alemán
si rusia invade eso significa que
tanques o tropas crucen la frontera de
ucrania
entonces no habrá north stream 2
sin embargo scholz reiteró que la
cooperación entre los europeos y eeuu
prevalecerá esa pobreza como ya dije
estamos actuando juntos estamos
absolutamente unidos y no tomaremos
pasos diferentes daremos los mismos
pasos y serán muy duros contra rusia
esta escalada de tensiones ha sido
calificada por la otan como la peor
desde la guerra fría se dio por el
despliegue de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania
según la casa blanca- moscú ya habría
concentrado más de 100 mil tropas frente
a su vecino quien denuncia que rusia
quiere invadir el territorio ucraniano
con el antecedente de la anexión de la
península de crimea en 2014 y en
honduras ya hay una única junta
directiva del congreso después de dos
semanas en las que 17 diputados
disidentes no apoyaron al presidente del
legislativo que había respaldado la
presidenta xiomara castró nuestra
corresponsal en tegucigalpa kenia torres
nos cuenta más
la profunda crisis interna en el
congreso hondureño en el que dos juntas
directivas se disputaban el control del
mismo ha llegado este día a su fin con
la firma de un acuerdo histórico entre
el presidente del partido libertad y
refundación de la mandataria xiomara
castró y un grupo de diputados
disidentes del mismo partido encabezados
por jorge cálix quien este día se ha
comprometido a apoyar la decisión de la
mandataria y su junta directiva
propuesta encabezada por el
parlamentario luis redondo con esto se
pone fin a esta crisis que mantenía eso
sobre la gobernabilidad del país y que
impedía que castró llevara a cabo su
agenda legislativa encaminada a una
lucha frontal contra la corrupción y a
buscar soluciones a los profundos
problemas estructurales del país como la
pobreza la migración y los serios
problemas en materia de educación y
salud aunque el acuerdo se llevó a cabo
presidencial no estuvo la mandataria ya
que ella misma confirmó a través de sus
redes sociales que se encuentra positiva
por kobe de 19 estado de salud es
estable
ahora hablemos de las noticias del cobi
19 chile comenzó a vacunar con la cuarta
dosis a las personas mayores de 55 años
y el 10 de enero el país ya había
comenzado el refuerzo con las personas
inmunosuprimidas ahora amplía el
programa para gran parte de los adultos
todo esto en medio del avance de la
variante omicron que tiene los contagios
disparados en el país austral nuestra
corresponsal patricia luna nos cuenta
más desde santiago
chile inició el proceso de vacunación
masiva de la cuarta dosis a todas las
personas mayores de 55 años que hubieran
recibido su tercera dosis hasta agosto
de 2021 el propio presidente sebastián
piñera recibió esta misma mañana su
cuarta dosis dando así inicio a este
proceso de vacunación masiva que se
justifica según un comunicado de
presidencia porque se ha demostrado que
los efectos de las vacunas para los
contagios y también para los casos más
graves disminuyen a lo largo del tiempo
chile vive en este momento la cresta de
la tercera ola marcada por los contagios
récord del omicron se llegaron a
registrar 37 mil casos la semana pasada
la cifra más alta de toda la pandemia y
se registraban más de 31.000 en las
últimas 24 horas muy lejos de los 9 mil
casos máximos que se llegaron a
registrar en olas pasadas esto en un
momento en el que se sabe que más de 2,4
millones de chilenos ya se han
contagiado de ecobici en un día marcado
también por una triste cifra en la que
se superan los 40 mil fallecidos
y australia reabrirá por completo sus
fronteras a todos los vacunados a partir
del 21 de febrero casi dos años después
de cerrar las fronteras para frenar la
propagación del cob y 19 por primera vez
desde marzo de 2020 las personas podrán
viajar al país desde cualquier parte del
mundo siempre y cuando tengan al menos
dos dosis de una vacuna contra el
coronavirus
sólo queremos enfatizar en que deberá
proporcionar esa prueba de vacunación su
visa es una cosa pero su entrada a
australia requiere que también tenga dos
vacunas y creo que los eventos conocidos
a principios de año deberían haber
enviado un mensaje muy claro creo para
todos en todo el mundo que ese es el
requisito para ingresar a australia
inglés trier la tenista china peng shuai
volvió a desmentir que haya acusado a un
ex funcionario del partido comunista
chino de agredirla sexualmente a pesar
de que en noviembre ella misma denunció
en una de sus redes sociales que él la
había obligado a tener relaciones
sexuales
ahora la deportista afirmó en una
entrevista con el diario francés
l'equipe que nadie la forzó además
anunció que se retira del tenis
peng shuai lo califica como un enorme
malentendido en sus primeras
declaraciones en meses a medios
occidentales la estrella china del tenis
dijo el diario deportivo francés
l'equipe que nunca acusó a nadie de
agresión sexual peng también negó haber
desaparecido tras las supuestas
acusaciones tras la preocupación por su
bienestar a nivel internacional cuando
no se le vio en público durante semanas
nunca dije que alguien me hubiera
agredido sexualmente de ninguna manera
nunca desaparece es solo que mucha gente
como mis amigos o personas del coi me
enviaron mensajes y era simplemente
imposible responder a tantos en un post
ahora borrado en su perfil de weibo 20
acusó en noviembre a un antiguo
funcionario del partido comunista chino
de obligarla a mantener relaciones
cuando el equipo preguntó por qué había
desaparecido el post-punk dijo que
simplemente había querido borrarlo sin
dar más detalles después de tres semanas
de ausencia bng fue vista finalmente en
público en un evento de tenis juvenil la
asociación de tenis femenino dijo que
las imágenes aún no a las preocupaciones
por su bienestar la ex número uno del
mundo de dobles dijo que era una chica
normal y que no quería más revuelo
mediático en torno al asunto también
señaló que dejaría de competir culpando
a una lesión de rodilla que a un
prolongado parón en el juego debido a la
pandemia a veces es difícil decir adiós
y retirarse aunque ya no participe en
competiciones profesionales siempre se
de tenista la entrevista se realizó bajo
ciertas condiciones
peng recibió la mayoría de las preguntas
por adelantado y se pidió al equipo que
publicara las respuestas sin comentarios
aunque pen habla un inglés prácticamente
fluido la entrevista se realizó en
mandarín
llegamos al final de las noticias y los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]